[David] I'm very excited to be able to announce our new class
and we found a fantastic professor to teach it. Welcome!
[Wes] I'm Wes Weimer and I'm going to be your guide on a course
about programming languages. And I think that's the topic of ultimate mastery.
We're going to cover concepts from engineering, the liberal arts
and the sciences as we work together to build a web browser,
a program that reads in web pages and produces pictures as a result.
We're going to learn to understand HTML and Javascript
from the inside out, by writing a program that understands them.
Come join me!
CS 262: Programming languages. Taught by Professor Wes Weimer.